someone else facing their fears is 10
year old canadian roberta vitalia
she wowed judges once again on last
night's episode of america's got talent
and she
had previously nabbed the golden butter
during her first audition but this one
of a kind singer
continued to impress with her version of
you say by lauren diego
take a look
when you say
i cannot believe your age like even if
you were 27
and sounding like that your tone is so
beautiful
and it's effortless and i can't even
wait to see what you do for the rest of
your life like obviously it's gonna be
singing but like
all the potential you have is insane
congratulations thank you so much
america vote for her i'm so proud of you
i'm so proud that i'm from toronto and
you're from toronto
you blow me away you i said to sophia
right after that i think that you have a
good chance of winning this whole season
number one
number two your voice is great and the
ability to sing through a horrible
butterfly attack like that is amazing
okay so on youtube uh lee simone is
saying oh my god her voice is amazing
jen is saying wow she's incredible and
she has no nerves
she's so amazing noah is saying roberta
is 10. question mark
she is incredible visario's saying
roberta is from toronto
love her yeah i got to interview her the
first time she got a gold
buzzer from sofia vergara um and she was
she's just so cool she's 10 years old
and then she you know opens her mouth
and has this incredibly mature voice so
what did you guys think of her
performance
it's it's powerful like i
no singing you go you go you go
technical issues we're
we're kind of delayed yeah you know her
first performance was absolutely amazing
and even her second performance
when she started singing the lady gaga
version uh of shallow
i was like that deep voice she had at 10
years old
uh you know it's absolutely amazing and
i as howie said i hope she goes really
far
with it the fact that she's in canada
makes it even more special but
that voice is incredible she is going to
be someone that we're going to see in
the future either way even if she
doesn't win or if she doesn't even go
further with this
uh she has a talent keisha when did you
know you started
you knew you had that voice oh my
goodness um well i started when i was
six years old
and i sang a lot and performed as many
places as possible but
i don't think i realized i had like a
voice voice
until maybe grade five i auditioned for
the grade
six play and i knew i wasn't really
allowed to be in the grade six play
um but i remember performing and
everybody cried and
uh i got a part and it was such a huge
deal to be the young one in the
and that's when i was like okay i can do
it but my mom had always been telling me
i could sing i just
don't think i believed it until my
classmates had tears in their eyes um
but she is so incredibly talented honey
if that was my 10 year old
i would be doing the same thing hey
honey america's got talent
okay one and two and three and four
sashay
that's what i would be doing i would be
like okay
now lunacy is saying can we trade kelly
for simon so as you notice that was
kelly clarkson she's not usually on the
show but of course simon heard his back
um on an e-bike i believe and so she's
filling in for him
do you i mean no one can replace simon i
mean let's be honest here i watch the
show for simon just hear his critiques
but
are you like now kelly's filling him for
him
yeah it's a great fit i think she's
perfect for it i mean she's a singer
herself
and uh uh you're right the reason i
watch it partly is to see what simon has
to say
and that's kind of funny because you
know he's not always the nice guy but
his critiques are important and we kind
of learn from what he says you're like
oh i didn't even notice that and so yeah
i'm
looking forward to simon coming back but
kelly's a great option for sure
yeah i need a new record
oh thank you um well i love i love kelly
just because she is a mom
and she's gonna have that nurturing side
and the girl she's 10 years old
so you need that kind of environment
around you to support you and uplift you
um but simon cowell is needed tough love
is needed the greats of the greats
are great because their parents are
tough on them i hate to say it that is
just how it is in music
if you look at michael jackson's dad to
beyonce's dad
you need you need people who are going
to be critical of you and you're going
to need to
have tough skin because this industry is
so
crazy that if you don't have tough skin
it doesn't matter how
talented you are that's not me sorry but
that is me sirens going by my house and
it's gone sorry about that